el desierto de néguev fue el escenario
escogido para un encuentro en el que
israel mostraría sus cálidas relaciones
con sus vecinos árabes únicas después de
años de hostilidad todo lo que se habló
fue sobre cooperación y consolidación de
la paz un cambio posible gracias a los
acuerdos de abraham negociados por la
administración trump en 2020
atenc bowie ertzaintza y first day es
change in tener creo que lo que estamos
tratando de hacer aquí es cambiar la
narrativa crear un futuro diferente y
construir una esperanza para nosotros y
nuestros hijos y nietos en fort william
grant cakes pero hay intereses en el
mundo real que unen a estas naciones
las capacidades compartidas que estamos
construyendo intimidan y disuaden a
nuestros enemigos comunes en primer
lugar y danny sus representantes élites
proxies en medio de las conversaciones
con teherán para revivir el acuerdo
nuclear de 2015 anthony blinken aseguró
a sus homólogos que washington continúa
trabajando para contrarrestar las
amenazas de seguridad iraníes
pero los lazos más estrechos aquí han
llevado a una ruptura en otros lugares
por ejemplo los territorios palestinos
eeuu enfatizó que la normalización de
las relaciones iguala al progreso en la
resolución del conflicto entre israel y
palestina cuyas conversaciones se
encuentran estancadas desde 2014 el
primer ministro palestino condenó la
cumbre
a menos que termine la ocupación las
reuniones árabes de normalización no son
más que una ilusión y una recompensa
gratuita para israel
israel mantiene la puerta para que los
representantes palestinos participen en
futuras interacciones de este evento